this episode of real science is brought
to you by brilliant master concepts in
math and science for 20% off by being
one of the first 200 people to sign up
at brilliant org slash real science at
this point no one is oblivious to the
impact the novel coronavirus is having
on society
millions infected tens of thousands dead
financial markets in ruin people out of
work social isolation and everyone
wondering when will this end and this is
the hardest question to answer we are in
uncharted waters
currently experts estimate the worst of
the impact should be over in a few
months but even after this initial surge
is over there is a chance that the virus
will persist in the population coming
back again and again there is also a
chance that the virus could act
seasonally recurring every winter
scientists and well everyone fiercely
hoped that this isn't the case but
there's a possibility it just doesn't go
away on its own and even after only a
few weeks everyone can feel that this
lockdown is unsustainable if the virus
does come back again next year the
prospect of shutting the world down
again is devastating there is an urgent
need to find a way to prevent new
infections and because of this the race
for a vaccine is on right now there are
at least 35 different vaccines in
preliminary stages around the world
researchers are moving at breakneck
speeds and progress is being made
ridiculously fast and the most promising
vaccines right now are ones that are
very different from the traditional
vaccines we all know about this type of
vaccine is called an RNA vaccine and if
successful could revolutionize the way
we prevent infectious disease just like
normal vaccines RNA vaccines get the
body to produce antibodies which can
attack potential pathogens but they do
so in a totally different way and
scientists think that this simple yet
groundbreaking concept could be the way
to stop corona virus in its tracks
vaccines are one of Medicine's greatest
inventions and prevent an estimated two
to three million deaths every year
vaccines have eradicated smallpox
reduced global child mortality rates and
prevented countless birth defects and
lifelong disabilities such as paralysis
from polio historically vaccines work by
introducing a weaker form of the virus
to the body or by introducing a dead
form of it
these are called live attenuated
vaccines and inactivated vaccines the
viruses disease-causing traits are
removed before being injected into the
body when these modified versions of the
pathogen are introduced to the body the
immune system recognizes the antigens
that coat their surface just as the body
would in an actual infection the immune
system reacts to these antigens by
making certain types of white blood
cells called t-cells and b-cells t-cells
attack cells in the body that have
already been infected and b-cells
produce antibodies that attack the viral
antigens the antibodies bind with the
antigens on the modified pathogens just
as they would with the disease-causing
pathogens this blocks them from
infecting more cells and allows the body
to destroy them once the vaccine
pathogens are destroyed the body is left
with the supply of T and B cells that
will remember how to fight that specific
disease in the future this type of
vaccine can be very effective at
preventing certain diseases but the way
they are manufactured means they are not
always a great solution when a novel
sudden outbreak like the corona virus
happens because making these vaccines
often takes a huge amount of time and
resources the seasonal flu vaccine
provides a good example as to why the
process is cumbersome because the key to
making it is lots and lots of eggs egg
based vaccines manufacturing is used to
make both the inactivated vaccine the
flu shot and the live attenuated vaccine
the nasal spray vaccine and they have
been making them this way for the last
70 years the process begins when the
candidate flu virus is injected into
fertilized chicken eggs they are then
incubated for several days to allow the
viruses to replicate for inactivated
influenza vaccines the viruses are then
killed and the virus antigen is purified
for live attenuated
vaccines the process is even more
involved they have to be modified to no
longer be infectious to humans but
remain similar enough to the original
virus to produce an immune response this
is done by allowing the virus to mutate
over time inside the chick cells it
slowly becomes more adapted to infect
chicken cells and less adapted to infect
human cells then when reintroduced to
the body as a vaccine the weakened virus
multiplies less quickly in humans and
gives the immune system time to mount an
antibody response but as you can expect
this process takes a long time
production can take months an eternity
when there is a deadly virus circulating
the globe propagating the viruses in
question is also expensive and requires
a massive number of eggs it takes about
one egg to make one vaccine some of the
corona virus vaccine development
projects are using these more
traditional approaches but others are
using newer technology to try to
circumvent these problems one company
moderna
is leading the charge in creating an
mRNA vaccine that could be the first of
its type approved for human use and the
vaccine called mrna 1 to 73 could become
the first coronavirus vaccine available
to the public the development of the
vaccine began when the entire genome of
the corona virus was sequenced in
January of this year and uploaded to a
public database scientists then
identified the sequence within the
genome for a key protein on the surface
of the virus called the spike protein as
a good vaccine candidate the spike
protein is a surface protein that the
corona virus uses to bind to a human
cell receptor allowing it to gain entry
into the cell it is one of the major
antigens of the corona virus that the
human body can make antibodies against
the nucleic acid sequence that codes for
the spike protein in the virus was then
encoded into an instruction molecule a
messenger RNA the mRNA molecule can then
be replicated many times and
administered to patients directly as a
vaccine the mRNA then travels throughout
the body and eventually instructs some
immune cells like macrophages or
dendritic cells to make copies of the
spike protein the spike protein antigen
is then displayed on the cell surface of
the immune cells that have taken up the
mRNA the presence of the spiked protein
lets the immune system think it has been
infected by the coronavirus immune cells
then learn about the spiked protein and
mount an immune response against it
the immune cells that develop then
remain in the body and can protect the
person if they ever come in contact with
the actual coronavirus this novel
approach is promising because the virus
itself doesn't have to be propagated to
make a vaccine this cuts out a
time-consuming process and instead uses
the human body in a sense to manufacture
its own vaccine in contrast to the
months required to make traditional
vaccines RNA vaccines can be made in the
lab in approximately one week using
readily available materials and because
it is relatively easy to encode mRNA
with any nucleic acid sequence
variations of the vaccine can be made
quickly to using the same production
methods and manufacturing facilities
this in particular could become vital
for viruses that mutate allowing
vaccination efforts to be more nimble
and adaptable to changing circumstances
a recent study used mice to test the
effectiveness of RNA vaccines for a
range of infectious diseases including
the Ebola virus h1n1 influenza and
Toxoplasma gondii eye they found that it
was successful in fully protecting
against lethal exposures to these deadly
pathogens DNA and RNA vaccines have also
been used for years in veterinary
medicine for diseases like rabies and
dogs foot and mouth disease and cows and
even a bronchitis caused by a different
form of corona virus and chickens the
scientific basis for the corona virus
RNA vaccine is sound and if it can be
produced so quickly why isn't it already
out there the science of mRNA vaccines
may be proven in animal models but it
will still require a lot of testing in
humans before it can be released to the
general public
vaccine developers have to be very
careful in developing any product that
is going to be injected into potentially
most of the world's population the
trials need to rule out if the vaccine
could be ineffective or worse unsafe the
main risk that researchers need to be
careful to avoid as a phenomenon called
disease enhancement this is when
vaccinated people who do get infected
with the actual virus develop a more
severe form of the disease than people
who had never been vaccinated and this
does come up on occasion in clinical
trials in the 1960s a vaccine was
produced against a common respiratory
virus that causes cold like symptoms and
children in clinical trials the vaccine
was found to make the symptoms worse in
infants who went on to catch the virus
and more recently a similar thing
happened to animals given an early
experimental SARS vaccine because of
risks like this these trials have to be
taken extremely seriously and they
usually take place in three phases
after a vaccine candidate has been
tested in laboratory animals phase one
of the clinical trials begins where the
vaccine is first introduced into humans
this usually involves a few dozen
healthy volunteers and test the vaccine
for safety phase two involves several
hundred people usually in a part of the
world affected by the disease or in
groups of people who the vaccine is
intended for and again monitors for
safety and also efficacy the third phase
does the same in several thousand people
and because of this long but important
process vaccines usually do not get
regulatory approval for ten years or
more but for the new vaccines being
developed researchers and regulators are
trying to fast-track that process while
also trying to not cut any corners they
acknowledge that the risk of disease
enhancement is low but the risk of not
getting vaccines advanced quickly and
more and more people dying is high
moderna has broken records with how
quickly they moved from obtaining the
genetic sequence to developing a vaccine
ready for human testing just 42 days
phase one of testing for the MRNA
vaccine has just begun with the first
ever person being injected with the new
vaccine just days ago some think the
vaccine could be ready for regulatory
approval in 18 months that feels like
ages when it seems like the world is
crumbling around us but is in fact
lightning speed for this process
one of the reasons their vaccine
development has been so fast is the work
they've done over the past two years
working to develop a vaccine against the
MERS virus so when the company received
the coronavirus genomic sequence in
January the stage was already set
however the 18-month timeline is still
an optimistic one basically everything
has to go right in all three phases of
the clinical trials to allow the vaccine
to be ready for 2021 if they can pull it
off it would be a world record but even
if it takes longer the development will
be groundbreaking mRNA vaccines are
likely going to be a big part of the way
we prevent infectious diseases in the
future and can hopefully be a powerful
tool in the toolbox in any future viral
outbreak as this situation unfolds
around us most of us are trying to stay
safe informed and hopeful about the
future while also taking care of
ourselves the best we can those of us
with free time on our hands find
ourselves wondering how we can make the
most of this period this is a great time
to read the books do the projects and
learn the skills that we've had on our
to-do lists for ages so if you're a
student looking to stay on top of your
studies someone hoping to brush up on
cutting-edge topics or someone who just
wants to use this time to understand the
world better you should check out the
math and science learning resources on
brilliant with brilliant
you can add some learning structure to
your daily routine by setting a goal to
improve yourself and then working at
that goal a little bit every day
brilliant makes it easy with interactive
challenges graphs and quizzes that make
your learning really hands-on brilliance
library includes a course on
computational biology if you want to
dive deeper into mRNA vaccines and how
they work the course develops an
intuition for a selection of
foundational concepts in molecular
biology like how the structure of DNA
and RNA make them such great information
storage molecules and eventually builds
up to cutting-edge problems in biology
like RNA folding so if you want to build
your problem-solving skills or just want
to spend this era of free time doing
something productive then sign up for
brilliant premium to learn something new
the interactive content is a really
great way to learn especially compared
to
of lecture-style learning and over time
you'll be amazed at what you've mastered
[Music]
you